let me start by saying how much i
appreciate
everything you and your team have done
also together with patricia over the
last
couple of weeks and months and all of us
have been heavily engaged in getting us
here
but having listened to the first couple
of interventions
i wonder if we're not at risk
of stumbling in this marathon a couple
of meters before reaching at the finish
line
and i just want to do one thing now
i have my list
of points i agreed with the ministers of
the eu this morning that i would bring
to the table and ask for your attention
and ask them to be incorporated or um
given due attention
but i want all of us here
every single one of you
to just for a minute think about one
person in your life
one person only
that will still be around in 2030 and
how that person will live
if we do not stick to the 1.5 degrees
here today
and of course we all have our national
interests and of course there are many
issues that need to be
looked at later and i fully understand
when developing nations say there should
be more finances on the table and yes
we're only at the beginning
of what we need to do on loss and damage
yes we're only at the beginning of um
adaptation finance and everything that
needs to be done absolutely
but for heaven's sake
don't kill this moment
by asking for more text different text
deleting this deleting that
everyone's been heard by the presidency
over the last couple of months a lot of
respect to every single country in this
room was given by the presidency over
the last couple of months and it is my
firm belief that the text that is on the
table now reflects perfectly well
this respect shown
by the presidency and at the same time
allows us to act with the urgency that
is essential for our survival
so i please implore you
please embrace this text
so that we can bring hope to the hearts
of our children and grandchildren
they're waiting for us they will not
forgive us if we fail them today